[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
لي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور تتكون مباشره من
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه من منطقه كتارا
تحديدا
وضمن اجواء مونديال قطر 2022 هذه المنطقه
المشجعين في البدع في حديقه البدع الذين
يوصلون متابعه مباراه صربيا والبرازيل في
انتظار بدايه الشوط الثاني اما هذه الصور
فتاتيكم من ريو دي جانيرو حيث يتابع
البرازيليون ايضا فريق بلادهم في قطر في
اول مواجهته في المونديال في انتظار اذن
الشوط الثاني
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد مباحثات جديده لوزراء الطاقه الخلافات
الاوروبيه تحول دون تحديد سقف باسعار
الغاز الروسي بايدي يؤكد ان الجهود وضع حد
اقصى لسعر النفط ما زالت قائمه وبوتن يحذر
من العواقب على السوق العالميه ويواجه
لعدم بيع النفط لمن يعتمد سقفا لسعر النفط
والغاز الروسي
بعد قصف روسيا استهدف بنا تحتيه ومشات
للطاقه عوده تدريجيه للكهرباء الى كيف
ومدن اخرى الرئيس الاوكرانيه يقول ان
الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه تؤكد ان موسكو
ليست لديها نيه للتفاوض انهاء الحرب واسكت
تؤكد انها هجماتها استهدفت انظمه التحكم
والقياده العسكريه الاخرانيه فقط
على واقعي ترقب لعمليه عسكريه تركيه
محتمله في شمال السوري قصف تركي متواصل
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
اكار يبلغ شويكو عزما انقره مواصله الرد
على ما وصفه بتهديدات المنظمات الارهابيه
ويؤكد ضروره الالتزام بالاتفاقيات السابقه
بهذا الشان واشنط تطالب بوقف فوري للتصعيد
في شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان الصين تسجيلا نحو
واحد وثلاثين الف اصابه جديده بفيروس
كورونا خلال يوم امس والاجراءات الصارمه
التي تتبعها الحكومه في المدن والمقاطعات
الاكثر تضررا
لاستطلاعي ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل ترون ان
ارتفاع اعداد الاصابات في الصين مؤشر
لعوده الجائحه
اثنين واربعون في المئه نعم باعتبارهم
مؤشرا على عوده محتمله للجائحه بينما
ثمانيه وخمسون في المئه جابوا بلا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
ولقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا يوم مونديال جديد
البرتغال تنتزع فوزا صعبا من غانا خساره
مفاجاه للكاميرون امام السويسرا وتعادل
سلبي بين الاورغواي وكوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
وبعد الحصاد مباشره تحديدا في الساعه
12:05 بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون الجوله
الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال والتي
ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم
قطر
2022 يقدمها الليله معذب
اخفق وزراء الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي في
التوسل الى اتفاقا بشان ووضعي سقفا لاسعار
الغاز الروسي وذلك بعد تقديم المفاوضات
الاوروبيه مقترحا اعتبرته بعض الدول غير
ذات في المقابله اتفق وزراء والطاقه على
استيراد الغاز بشكل جماعي لتفادي المنافسه
كما اتفقوا على تسريع مشاريع الطاقات
البديله
وضعوا سقف لاسعار الغاز يفرق الاوروبي
اجتمعوا وزراء الطاقه في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لمناقشه مقترح قدمته مفوضيه
الاتحاد لكن هذا المقترح لم يرضي الراغبين
في وضع سقف للاسعار تقترح المفوضيه سقفا
يبدا العمل به اذا تجاوزت الاسعار
275 يورو لكل ميغاوات ساعي لمده اسبوعين
واذا كانت اعلى ب 85 يورو من سعر الغاز
الطبيعي المسالي في الاسواق العالميه قالت
وزيره المناخ البولنديه ان السقف الاسعار
الوارده في وثيقه المفوضيه يبدوك طرفه ولا
يرضي احدا فلماذا لا يرد مقترح المفوض
احدا داخل الاتحاد الراغبون في وضع سقف
للاسعار يقارنون مقترحه 275 يورو مع
الشروط التي رافقته باسعار الغاز حاليا في
اوروبا وهي نحو 124 يورو لكل ميجاوات ساعي
ويقولون انه في هذه الحاله تبدو حظوظ
وضعها هذا السقف ضئيله جدا
تبدو هذه الدروه وهي 15 دوله تقودها فرنسا
واسبانيا وايطاليا وبولندا محبطه من مقترح
مفوضيه الاتحاد الاوروبي ترى هذه الدول ان
هذا السقف ضروري لحمايه الاقتصاد والاسر
من اي زياده كبيره في الاسعار مثل ما حدث
خلال اغسطس خصوصا اذا كان فصل الشتاء
باردا جدا اما الدور الرافضه لوضع سقف
للاسعار وتقودها المانيا فبعضها يتخوف من
توقف الامدادات الروسيه وبعضها الاخر
يتخوفه من ان يؤدي وضعه هذا السقف الى
تغيير المصدرين وجههم نحو اسواق تدفع اكثر
خصوصا في اسيا يؤثرها هذا الخلاف الاوروبي
ايضا على جهود مجموعه السبع لوضع حد اقصى
لسعر نفط روسيا المنقول بحرا في محاوله
لحرمانها من مداخيل ترى انها تمول بها
حربها على اوكرانيا تتفرج موسكو على هذا
الانقسام الاوروبي وتذكر بمواقفها قال
الكريمنين ان روسيا لن توردن النفط والغاز
للدول الداعمه لسقف الاسعار وذكر الناطق
باسم الكربلاند متر بيسكوف باصدار الرئيس
بلادي من بوتين تعليمات بعدم تصدير النفط
والغاز للدول التي تضع سقفا للاسعار وقالت
خارجيه الروسيه ان محاولات الاتحاد
الاوروبي وضع سقفي للاسعار الغاز ستخلق
سابقه خطيره وتهدد بحدوده ركود عالمي يغلب
على موضوع سقف اسعار الغاز التابعه
والاقتصادي لكنه بعده السياسي لا يقل
اهميه فالاوروبيون يحاولون اظهار وحده
الصف اما بوتين وهذا الخلاف يظهر انهم لم
يحققوا ذلك بعد
طبعا الانقسام الاوروبيه الحلي هو بشان
السقف اسعار الغاز اما بشان سعر النفط فان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في تصريحات
للصحفيين الخميس يقول ان مقترح واشنطن
والحلفاء بوضعه سقفا على السعر المشط
الروسي لا زالوا قائما مضيفين انه تحدث
الى وزيره الخزانه جانه يلد بهذا الشان
وفي المقابل قال الكريم لان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اكد في اتصال مع رئيس
الوزراء العراقي انا وضع سقفا لسعر النفط
الروسي ستكون له عواقبه وخيمه على اسواق
الطاقه العالميه وانا مثل هذه الممارسات
تتعارض ومبادئ علاقات السكر وكانت وكاله
تاسه روسيه نقلت عن المتحدث باسم الكرملين
قوله بوتن اصدرت تعليمات بعدم تصدير النفط
والغاز للدول التي تضع سقفا للاسعار
معنى الان من موسكو
الخبير في شؤون النفط والطاقه وعضو مجلس
الخبراء في وزاره الطاقه الروسيه ومن
بروكسل معنى ماركو جولي المستشار السابق
لسياسات الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي اهلا
بكما في الحصاد وابدا معك سيد ماركو جوليت
نريد ان نفهم ما هو جوهر الخلاف الاوروبي
هذه المره والحديث هنا عن تحديد السقف
لسعر النفط الروسي بينما كانت هناك خلافات
في السابق على اموره كثيره
ان هناك
اقصى لسعر الغاز والاخر حول السعر النفط
هناك بلدان تدفع باتجاه الى الحد الاقصى
وايضا
ماليه
ازمه الاسعار الحاليه لكن هناك بلدان اخرى
ايضا التي ترى ان
السعر الاقصى الذي اقترحته مجموعه السبعه
هو متدنيا اكثر مما ينبغي بينما الاخرون
الذين ينحازون الى موقف في الوقت المتحده
يطالبون بدعم
للاعلى للابطاء على احتياجات السوق طيب
سواء كان يعني الخلاف التقني او او مبدئي
او بالنسبه لموضوع نفسه في النهايه
تحديد سقف
للغاز لسعر الغاز الروسي والسؤال هنا
للسيد فيتش لافا
كيف سيضع موقف روسي ما هي خياراتها في هذه
الحال
لان لعشرات السنوات كان هناك حديث عن حريه
في سياسه الاسعار في سوق الطاقه واا
هذه كانت من القيم الغربيه وكيف الان
يضعون سقف ويحددون سقف ومن سوف يقوم بهذه
باي طريقه هذا
يجعل هناك عدم تفاهم في اعضاء هذا الاتحاد
الطاقي اما بالنسبه للاتحاد الروسي
فبالنسبه لان هنا يوجد رؤيه واضحه جدا في
هذه الظروف الجديده وظروف
السقف الذي يريدون وضعه لن نقوم ببيعه
الطاقه وسوف يكون لدينا معاملات
معاكسه لما يقومون به معانا وهذه العلاقات
ايضا هذه النظره ايضا موجوده في الدول
العربيه التي تصدر الطاقه للسوق العالميه
لذلك هذه الاختلافات مهمه واساسيه لذلك
سوف كيف سوف نعمل في المستقبل همم لا احد
يستطيع ان يتخيل ما قد يحدث عندما يقوم
تقوم بعد الدول بتعديلات على السوق
العالميه بطرق غير مفهومه تماما هذه
القيود على الاسعار على
سوق حره تماما ولكن سيد ميشينكو تقول ان
روسيا لن تبيعها وهذا يعني ما قيل رسميه
همم انها لن تبيع لدول التي تحدد سقف
للغاز في الظل انقطاع امدادات الغاز هل هي
فعلا ورقه مؤثره بنسبه لروسيا
القضيه ليست في هذا في انها ورقه رابحه ام
لا القضيه عن حريه السوق العالميه هناك
الكثيرين من الذبائن والمشتريين بدول
عديده السكان في الدول سوف تستمر بالتعامل
معنا حسب قواعد السوق المشترك لذلك سوف
ننظر الى الاسعار التي سوف تعرض اما كميه
الانتاج هذا ما سوف ننظر به بغض النظر عن
تقييد كميه الانتاج بالنسبه
الروسي سوف نقوم همم التجاره حسب قواعد
الربح والخساره
يمكن ان تتحمل همم الدول الاوروبيه المزيد
من النقص في الامدادات في حال طبقت ماسك
هذا التهديد
سناب
الان الكميات المباعه من الغاز الروسي هي
اقل بكثير من المعتاد اذا ما اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار
الانابيب نقل الغاز هناك بلدان اوروبيه
قليله فقط
[موسيقى]
الروسيه قد تم قطعها من قبل
وعلى نفس الشكل هذا يمكن ان نطبقه نفس
المنطق على النفط كما هو على الغاز فلم
تعود هناك بلدان اوروبيه كثيره تشتري
النفط الروسي وايضا هناك قدره محدوده
لروسيا لاعادته توجيهي
فايقه نفسها في الاسواق العالميه
التعويل سيد ميشينكو هو على الصين والهند
هنا هل هذا فعلا كافي في هذه المرحله وكيف
سيؤثر على المشهد بشكل عام خصوصا ان عقود
النفط والغازيه عقود يعني طويله الاجل ولا
يمكن الاعتماد على تغيير هكذا بين ليله
وضحاها
[موسيقى]
العقود همم مبتدئه بنفسها ان موضوع الغاز
للمجتمع الاوروبي الى نعلم او ربما دول
ال- ال-
قمه السبعه يريد ان يضعوا هذه القيود على
اسعار النفط والغاز وهذا في الواقع يغير
جميع اساسات العقود هذا هي هذه
مدمره لنظام الاتفاقات الدوليه والتجاره
الدوليه لذلك في هذه الظروف من الصعب
نتخيل كيف سوف تكون التجاره وفي اي احد
اما بالنسبه للهند والصين فهذه اكبر دول
التي تستخدم الطاقه وبالنسبه لروسي سوف
نقوم بتوجيه همم
يجب ان نقول ان مصادر الطاقه الان هي تتش
الو هذه السلطه تتشكل بحسب احتياجات دول
اسيا
وسوف يكون هناك صعوبات بالطبع اللوجستيه
ومن جانب التمويل هذه الخطوط ولكن الحاجه
سوف تكون كبيره وسوف تتشكل بحسب احتياجات
هذه المنطقه
همم
وزاره الطاقه الروسيه من موسكو شكرا جزيلا
لك وشكرا لماركو ديالي همم مستشار السابق
للسياسات الطاقه في الاتحاد الاوروبي من
بروكسل
الان الى معركه اخرى بين روسيا والغرب
والتي تبرز فيها قضيه الاصول الروسيه
ومحاولات تجميدها اذ نقلت صحيفه الوصف عن
مصادر قولها ان الاداره الامريكيه تصطدم
بعقبات قانونيه في سعرها لمصادره الاصول
الروسيه المخفيه ومنحها لاوكرانيا واضافت
الصحيفه ان المددعين العامين الامريكيين
اصدروا مؤخرا مذكرات استدعاء للكشف عن
اصول روسيه في الولايات المتحده واشارت
الى ان مذكرات الاستدعاء للكشف عن اصول
روسيه في امريكا تحديدا تمهد لمصادره
عقارات وحسابات نقديه وصناديق ائتمانيه
هذا الملف ملف الاصول الروسيه ومحاولات
مصادرتها والعقبات القانونيه والمخاوف هو
ما سنناقشه بعد قليل في فقره في المتابعه
[موسيقى]
والان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
اذا افاد مراسل الجزيره في اوكرانيا
باستمرار القتال بين قوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على طرفي نهر دنبر في خرسه
الجنوبيه البلاد وذكر الجيش الاوكراني ان
قصفا روسيا مكثفا استهدفه 23 قريه في
خرسانه في اخر التطورات
الاوكرانيون انهم استطاعوا اعاده امدادات
المياه الى جميع احياء العاصمه كيف بعد
الضربات الصاروخيه التي استهدفت البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه وقالت السلطات الاوكرانيه
ان اعاده امداد الكهرباء لجميع مناطق
اوكرانيه تتم بشكل تدريجي
كان الجيش الاوكراني اعلن ان روسيا
استهدفت بسبعه وستين صاروخا مواقع عده
للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه في عمومي اوكرانيا
وكان عمده مدينه كييف بالتالي كلشينغ
اعلن ان فرق الصيانه في مجال الطاقه
الاوكرانيه استطاعت اصلاح الاضرار التي
لحقت بخطوط امدادات المياه في المدينه كما
اضاف عمده العاصمه الاوكرانيه ان النظام
الامداد سيستغرق وقتا كي يعمل بكامل طاقته
مشيرا الى ان فرق الصيانه تبذل جهودا
حثيثه لاستعاده مصادر الطاقه الكهربائيه
باسرع وقت ممكن لكن ذلك يعتمد على ما سماه
استعاده التوازن في نظام الطاقه في البلاد
هذا وكان ميخائيل بدليات مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني قال انه لا يمكن ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب بحل الوسط على حساب الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وحياه الاوكرانيين واضاف
ابوذيات في تغريده على تويتر انا روسيا
يجب ان تخسر في ساحه المعركه وان تدفع
ثمنا باهظا لما سماها جرائمها ضد
الانسانيه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نفت قصف
قواتها اهداف في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
مشدده على ان الدمار الذي لحق ببعض
المباني في الاحياء السكنيه كان نتيجه
صواريخ اطلقتها انظمه دفاع جوي للجيش
الاوكراني واكد المتحدث باسم الوزاره اجور
كوناشينكو انا ضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه
استهدفت نظام التحكم والقياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ومنشات الطاقه المرتبطه بها
من الان من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا في
الحصاد سياده العميد اذا استهداف تقول
اوكرانيا انه روسي وروسيا تنفي ولكن في
النهايه هناك منشات وبنا تحتيه تتضرر الان
كيف سيؤثر هذا على الجهد العسكري على اداء
القوات الاوكرانيه
لا لا انها حرب من نوع جديد يعني انها حرب
على ما يمكن ان يساعد على الصمود خلال
فتره الشتاء والشتاء قد بدا لنتحدث عن
التدفئه نتحدث عن الغاز نتحدث عن المياه
وهذا الامر يضرب عزيمه او اراده الشعب
الاوكراني وبالتالي قد يخلق مشكله لاجئين
الى الدول المحيطه في ظل حرب المستمره
يعني هذا امر يتم التعويض عنه لقاء ما حصل
على ارض المعركه من حركاب وحتى خرسان
والمعركه قادمه مستمره وهذا امر يعني حرب
من نوع جديده يعني عسكرت همم الخدمات
الاجتماعيه للناس
كيف سيؤثر على اداء القوات الاوكرانيه في
ظل هذه الظروف
انا اعتقد اليوم يؤثر بطريقه غير مباشره
لان الجبهات لا تزال قائمه لا تزال مهمه
لها شيء خاص فيها من سلاح من ذخيره وحتى
من يعني
اسلحه مضاده للطائرات او للدفاعات الجويه
اليوم ما يحصل هو اساسي لمزيد من السلاح
من نوع جديد لاوكرانيا الدفاعات الجويه
كما قيل حتى ان اليوم من ضمن ال 400 مليون
مساعده دولار امريكي هناك 200 مولد
كهربائي بدا تصل الى اوكرانيا وكانه اليوم
يتم اا ال- ال- يعني تحويل ال- ال- ال-
البنا التحتيه للقاء همم يعني مرحله يعني
بانتظار ان يكون هناك اصلاح وتعهد هناك ما
يعني مرحله انتقاليه سيؤثر على المعركه
لانه الجندي الذي يقاتل لديه العائله
موجوده في الكاف او موجوده في الناب او
موجوده في زفروجا فعلا سيؤثر بالمعنى
المعنوي بالمعنى الصمود هي ضرب اراده هذا
الموضوع وحتى ليلى اختبار اراده الغرب في
كيفيه الصمود للضغط على اوكرانيا للدخول
في حاله تفاوض مع روسيه حسب شروط روسيه
ولكن انت كنت اشارت الى خير الان يعني
خيرسون في علامه استفهام كبيره يعني كنا
تحدثنا كيف ان القوات الروسيه غادرتها الى
الضفه الاخرى منها
والان تعود الى قصفها بشكل مكثف
يعني ما المقصودن ما هي قراءتك العسكريه
هذا لما يجري في خيره تحديدا
الذهاب الى الضفه الشرقيه للنهر هناك
مرحله بناء دفاعات مهمه على طول هذا النهر
وبالتالي منع الدفاعات الاوكرانيه من
التمركز في الضفه الغربيه تحضيره لاي شيء
قد يخطط في المرحله القادمه اليوم
الدفاعات الجويه في الضفه الشرقيه من
الجهه الروسيه همم اقليم خرسان هي هي مهمه
لانها تحمي جزيره القرم لانها تحمي
المنطقه الشرقيه خاصه الى مدينه ميليتو
بول المدينه المحوريه الاساسيه
وتجري هناك ايضا دفاعات لانها المدخل الى
الجسم البري الذي يصل القرم بدهم بس وهي
مدخل الى ذا فروج همم الى المحطه النوويه
وما شابه هذا الامر مهم جدا خوفا من ان
يكون هناك عمليه للعبور الى هذا الجسر الى
نهدد النيترو وانا اعتقد انه من الصعوب
اليوم العبور
ليقول حسب الخبراء همم ليلى ان الرئيس
بوتين يقوم بكل هذه الامور تحذيرا لشيء قد
يكون في مرحله ما بعد الشتاء مرحله كاونتر
اتاك او عمليه هجوم ردي كامل وشاسي على كل
الجبهات من كركاب وحتى خرسان اشكرك جزيلا
العميد الياس حنا من بيروت
في مقابله مع فاينل تايمز قال الرئيس
الاوكراني بلودميرزنسكي انه لن يكون هناك
حل دائم للصراع دون انسحاب روسيا من جميع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه واضاف ذلك ان المساعي
الى حل لا يشمل السعاده شبه جزيره القرم
هي مضيعه على الوقت حسب تعبيره وشدد
الرئيس الاوكراني على ان الهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه تؤكد ان موسكو
ليست لديها نيه للتفاوض من اجل انهاء
الحرب
كثافه سلاح الجو التركي خلال الساعات
الماضيه قصفه على مناطق في المالكيه
والقامشلي والحسكه وعين العرب ودير الزور
في شمال سوريا وكان وزير الدفاع التركيه
خلصي اكار ابلغ نظيره الروسيه
التي تنطلق من شمال سوريا بشكل دائم ردا
على مطالبه شويكه تركيا بالامتناع عن شنهو
من وسع
مزيد من الضغوط الخارجيه على انقره لفنيه
عن شني عمليه بريه في الشمال السوري اخر
تلك الضغوط حملتها مكالمه وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شوريجو الى نظيره التركي خلص
يا كار
وفق وزاره الدفاع التركيه طالب بتجنب هجوم
واسع النطاق فرد اكار بان اولويه تركيا هي
درء التهديدات الارهابيه وبشكل دائم مذكرا
باهميه الامتثال للاتفاقيات السابقه في
هذا الشان وبعد يوم من اتصال رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه بنظره التركي مطالبا
اياه بالتهدئه دعت الخارجيه الامريكيه
تركيا الى وقف فوري للتصعيد في شمال سوريا
قائله على لسان المتحدث باسمها النواشر
تتفهم مخاوف انقر الامنيه المشروعه لكنها
تخشى جديه
تاثيرات ذلك على مواجهه تنظيم الدوله وعلى
المدنيين في المنطقه حتى الان على الاقل
لا يبدو ان تلك الضغوط المتلاحقه تنال من
تصميم انقره على المذي قدما في تهديداتها
مؤكده ان سعه الصفر ستكون في الوقت
الملائم وفي ضوء مشاورات يجريها القاده
السياسيون والعسكريون زينب زينب قوتنا
المسلحه والطائرات الحربيه تدمر اوكار
الارهابي بعملياتها في شمال العراق
والسوريه وهي الاماكن التي تم فيها
التخطيط للعمليات الارهابيه في تركيا هناك
اعضاء برلمان غير مرتاحين لهذا الامر اقول
لهم اننا سنكون حيث يكون الارهاب من خلال
مخابراتنا وقواتنا المسلحه
وفي اليوم الخامس من ما تسميه تركيا عمليه
المخلب السيف اردنا على تفجير اسطنبول
الدامي كسف سلاح الجو التركي غارته على
مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
واعلن المتحدث باسم تلك القوات مقتل عناصر
منها في غارات استهدفت محيط مخيم الهول
حيث يقبع الاف النازحين وافراد من عائلات
تنظيم الدوله في شمال شرق سوريا ولا تخلو
المواجهه في هذه المناطق من مخاطر لا سيما
بعد ان اكده القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
ان ضربه عسكريه تركيه استهدفت يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي قاعده عسكريه مشتركه
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والتحالف الدولي
بقيادته في محافظه الحسكه عرضت جنود
امريكيين للخطر وهي حوادث قد تش رافعه
للجماعات الكرديه المسلحه في هذه المواجهه
المنذره بالاسوا
محي الدين اتمان البحث في مركز سيتا
للدراسات ومن بوسن الدكتور ماكس ابرامز
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه نورسن
اهلا بكم في الحصاد
في الواقع نحاول ان نفهم هذا التحفظ يعني
في النهايه هناك تحفظ امريكي وروسي كل من
زاويته وسؤال سيد محي الدين اتامان
وهذا التحفظ الى اي حد يؤثر على فرص ذهاب
تركيا همم
بعمليه عسكريه بريه في شمال سوريا
ولد يونيون
اولويه تركيه الاولى هو التخلص من هذا
المنظمات الارهابيه على الاراضي السوري
اذا التحفظات الامريكيه او الروسيه لم
ترضع تركيا عن قيامها بما ينبغي في الردعي
المنظمات الارهابيه في شمال سوريا للاسف
كل من الالات المتحده وروسيا كانت عماني
بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في المنطقه اذا تركيا وهذا
طبيعي كانت تتوقع
وتنتظر الظرطه المناسب والوقت
المناسبني هذه العمليه البريه لذلك انا
اعتقد انه
المتحده ولا السياسيه تحولان دون
القيام بالهجوم وعندما تقرر تركيا ذلك
المشكله هنا هي ان هناك امم النقاط رؤيا
مختلفه من
في النظر الى الازمه السوريه لا ينفع
علينا ان ننتظر التطورات المستقبليه
والامر يعتمد على تصور تركيا
للوقائع والظروف على الارض وهذا ما سيقرر
القيامه بعمليه ام لا
في النهايه يعني هناك تحفظ تركي واضح على
العلاقه بين واشنطن وجماعات تعتبرها تركيا
ارهابيه وتهدد اراضيها
كيف
ستعلق وتتعامل واشنطن مع هذا الموقف
انا لا اختلف مع زميلي
فنحن نرى بان الامر واضح فان تركيا سوف
تغزو شمال تركيا
حتى الان
واعتقد ان لحد الان اعتقد ان القضيه تسير
ذلك الاهتمام الكبير لدار راي العالم
الامريكي هؤلاء المقاتلون الاكراد الذين
يشكلون الحلفاء الرئيسيين للواتساب
المتحده في الحرب ضد الارهاب لهذا سبب
الولايات المتحده ستكون
فعلى الدفاع عنهم ضد تركيا لكن الامر قد
يختلف قليلا الان ومراد ذلك جزئيه ان
الولايات المتحده منشغله في الحرب في
اوكرانيا وهي تضخ
المليارات من الدعم العسكري والسلاحي
هناك مشكلات مثلا هناك بلدان مثل الفنلندا
والسويده والثاني تريدان الانضمام الى
تركيا وان لو ان امريكا همم
سارت السياقه تركيا كثيره فان تركيا قد
تعرض الانضمامهم لهذا السبب فان حاله
التقبل التركي لذلك قد تتاثر بهذا السبب
انا ارى الامور بهذه الطريقه
لمتابعه هذا النقاش من موسكو اليكساندر
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
ايضا لنتعرف على وجهه النظر الروسيه هنا
في ما يجري حاليا في شمال سوريا والهجمه
المحتمله التركيه همم يعني كان ضيفنا
الامريكيه يتحدث عن ان ربما الانشغال
بالحرب الاوكرانيه قد دفع الولايات
المتحده لتبدي نبره اقل من التحفظ ولكن
ليس هناك احد منشغل بالحرب الاوكرانيه
اكثر من روسيا نفسها وهي تتحفظ على عمليه
بريه تركيه محتمله ما هي النقاط التي
تدفعها لذلك
نيكولا
اذا ممكن
تدفع روسيا للتحفظ على هجمه اييي تركيا
بريه محتمله في شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
وتعاونت مع جولين
ولذلك ما حدث في الاستقلال في سن في مركز
اسطنبول
عن
حزنها لما حدث تحت اداره
الامريكان بعد قتل الكثير من الاشخاص ان
الامريكان كانوا يعزوهم بعد ما قتلوا
هؤلاء الاشخاص ان دعم همم
روسيا لتركيا ااه مستمر
خاص السيد طيب اردوغان لا يريد ان يخدم
المصالح الامريكيه او الاوروبيه انه يلعب
لعبته الخاصه وهذا ايضا ربما يكون بعيد عن
اللعبه الروسيه ولكنها ايضا بعيده عن
اللعبه الامريكيه لقد طلب من الامريكان ان
يبعد صواريخهم مقالب لهم الذريه من مناطق
سوريا ومن المعروف ان في قاعده اندرليك
همم
هو النظام جديد يقوم نقوم ببناءه ان
النظام الدولي القديم قد هلك ولم يعود الى
الحياه
تتفهم الموقف التركي
ولا تعترض ربما على الرد ولكنها تتحفظ على
النوع وهو هذا محور السؤال سيد محي الدين
امان في المكالمه التي جرت اليوم بين
شويكو
لم ااه كن هناك اشاره الى ضربر بريه او
تحرك بري كان هناك حديث عن همم هدف همم
الهدف وتحديد الخطر الارهابي كما تم وصفه
همم هل هذا ربما يشير الى ان تركيا قد
تكتفي فعلا
بقصف جوي على مناطق حددتها كان الحديث
عنها بالامس في البيان التركي باكثر من
470 هدف هل هذا ما يمكن ان يتوقعه
اجزاكت يونيون تركيا
[موسيقى]
داخل الحدود التركيه واستمرت لتهديد الامس
المنطقه فان تركيا سوف تزيد من ردودها
الانتقاميه ضد هذه المنظمات الارهابيه
واوربما
ايه
ناتج
هذا امر الطبيعي بيبحث هذا الموضوع مع
الجانب الروسي لانه فيما تعلقوا بالازمه
السوريه الدوله الروسيه هي اكثر تفهما من
ذرات المتحده للاسف الوقت المتحده كانت
تغلقه كل الابواب تقريبا بوجه تركيا ولا
تشارك تركيا بواعي ثقلقها الامنيه وتستمر
بالادعاء بان قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تشكل
التوازنا ضد داعش لكن هذا لم يعد واقع
الحال لم يعد هناك اي تهديد من داعش على
الاطلاق من الجانب السوري لكن يستمر في
التعاون مع هذه المنظمه فقط من اسئله
الحصول على
موارد طبيعيه ولا اهداف السياسيه
للاسف جزء من سياسه الملكه في سواء تركيا
لهذا السبب قد نتوقع من تركيا ان ترسل
بقواتها البريه الى داخل الاراضي السوريه
وكثيرون ياملون همم كثير كان يعملون هذا
سيكل الاستنزافا
للقوات التركيه لكن تركيا لم تسقط في هذا
الفخ ستجر حساباتها وتنتظر للوقت المناسب
والظروف المناسبه للقيام بهذا العمليه
البريه
في حال السيد ماكس ابراهامز قررت تركيا ان
الظروف فعلا مناسبه لتحرك من هذا النوع
كيف ستتعامل الولايات المتحده بايجاز لو
سمحت مع هذا التحرك
تمام
وانا بصراحه لا اعرف ماذا سيفعلون ازاءها
في حملته الانتخابيه ضد ترامب انتقد بعض
ترامب لان هو الرضا
للافراد
الاتراك عفوا بصحبه قوته من شمال سوريا
الان تركيا وهي على تهاجمه
تهاجم التركي
لا نسمع الكثير
اذا هذا وضع يدل على ان الولايات المتحده
استاذ معنيه لكن اعتقد انها تتدخل عسكريا
شكرا
رمز استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه مؤته
واشكر محي الدين اتمنى الباحث في مركز
سيتالي للدراسات وشك
اليكساندر همم الخبير في الشؤون الع
الاستراتيجيه من مصر
الجيش التركي وخلال السنوات الماضيه نفذ
اكثر من عمليه عسكريه بريه وجويه شمال
سوريا العمليات البريه وغيرها استهدفت
اكثر من طرف من تنظيم الدوله الى المسلحين
الاكراد وصولا الى قوه النظام السوري
نتعرف على هذه العمليات في الاستعراض
التاليه
[موسيقى]
لان الى الصين والخبر الذي تناولناه في
فقره قبل الحصاد بشان جائحه كورونا اذا
اعلنت السلطات هناك
31 الف اصابه جديده بفيروس كورونا خلال
يوم امس الاربعاء في الصين متجاوزه بذلك
الرقم القياسي الذي تم تسجيله في ابريل
الماضي اعلان
والاجراءات الصارمه التقرير التالي لشيماء
جو اي اي من بيجي
في احد اكبر مصانع هواتف ايفون بالعالم لم
تخلو من صدمات مع رجال الامن مشاهد ضجه
بها وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينيه قبل
حضرها لاحقا فعدد من عمال مصنع فوكس
اشتكون من ظروفهم الصحيه بسبب منعهم من
مغادره المصنع منذ اسابيع هي سياسه الحلقه
المغلقه التي تتبعها الصين لمنع تفشي
الفايروس والتي تحطم على افواجا من العمال
عدم مغادره المرافق حيث خطوط الانتاج
اما الوضع في العاصمه الصينيه بيتين فلا
يختلف كثيرا صفائح تصديريه لعزل مجمعات
سكنيه باكملها بعد اكتشاف حاله اصابه فيها
مع اغلاق المطاعم والمقاهي والاماكن
الترفيهيه وطوابير طويله لاجراء الفحص
الاجباري يوميا
وعدده الاصابات في الارتفاع على مستوى
البلاد وهو بمتوسط 20,000 حاله يوميا هذا
الاسبوع اي ضعف اجمالي الاصابات الاسبوع
الماضي اجراءات الاغلاق لا تصب في صالح
الاقتصاد الصيني الذي شهيدا كماشا بنسبه
تجاوزت اثنين في المئه خلال نصف الاول من
العام الحالي بسبب سياسه صفر كبد التي
تتبعها الحكومه فهو اليوم في اسوا حالاته
منذ ظهور الفيروس عام 2020 وفق خبراء
منذ نحوي ثلاث سنوات يعيش الصينيون على
وقع الاغلاقات المتكرره فمفهوم التعايش مع
الفيروس هنا لا يعني بالنسبه للحكومه
تخفيف الاجراءات الوقائيه الصارمه الامر
الذي يزيد حاله الاحتقان في الاوساط
الاجتماعي ويثقل كاهل الاقتصاد الصيني
شيماء شويى الجزيره
[موسيقى]
طبعا من يتابع مباراه صربيا والبرازيل هي
ما زالت مستمره 2 لصالح البرازيل على
العموم سنترك ذلك للفقره الرياضيه الان
نعود الى معركه في اطار اخر معركه تدور
رحاحها بين موسكو والدول الغربيه الداعمه
لكيف بشان الاصول الروسيه ومحاولات
تجميدها نائب رئيس مجلس الدومه انتقد
المحاولات الاوروبيه الفاشله حتى الان كما
وصفها قبل ان يضيف ان ما يحدث مسار خطير
من الناحيه القانونيه وله عواقب لا يمكن
التنبؤ بها
الدول الغربيه تبحث عن الصيغه قانونيه
لمصادره الاصول الروسيه المجمده
لاستخدامها في الحرب واعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا وقد كلف خبراء اللي النظر في
الخيارات القانونيه التي تبدو صعبه ومعقده
للغايه طبعا اي اجراء من جانب الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيركز على الاصول المملوكه في
اوروبا علما انه من غير الواضح على وجه
التحديد ما هي تلك الاصول التي تم تجميدها
في الاتحاد الاوروبي
كان مسؤولو وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه حذروا
في السابق من خطوه غير مسبوقه قد تثني
البنوك المركزيه الاجنبيه الاخرى عن ابقاء
اصولها في الولايات المتحده واضافوا ان
مصادر اصول البنك المركزي الروسي قد تكون
بمثابه حقل الغام قانوني
همم وكان طبعا
هناك قانون
لسلطه الطوارئ الاقتصاديه الدوليه لعام
1977 هذا القانون يمنح رئيس الولايات
المتحده السلطه كي يجمد الاصول المملوكه
لاجانب بما في ذلك ممتلكات دول اجنبيه
السؤال
ما لا يعنيه التجميد هو تغيير ملكيه تلك
الاصول وهناك استثناء نادر جدا في هذا
القانون يمنح الرئيس الحق في مصادره
الممتلكات الاجنبيه والتصرف فيها حين
تترقب الولايات المتحده اعمالادائيه مسلحه
او ان تتعرض للاعتداء من قبل دوله اجنبيه
او مواطنين اجانب
كان وزير العمل الروسي قدره قبل شهور
مبالغ بلاده التي جمدتها الدول الغربيه
بحوالي نصف احتياطيات روسيا من الذهب
والعملات الاجنبيه اي بنحو 300 مليار
دولار
وحده العمل التابعه للحلفاء الغربيين
المسؤولين عن تغلب او تعقب الاصول العائده
للنخب الروسيه قدرت ان الحلفاء الغربيين
جمدوا 30 مليار دولار من الاصول المملوكه
للاثرياء او النخب كذلك قدروا نحو 300
مليار دولار للبنك المركزي الروسي وحده
مشيره الى انه تم الحجز على عقارات مملوكه
يسيطر عليها رعايه روس فرضت عليهم عقوبات
ويندون دلاع الحرب كانت بريطانيا اعلنت
تجميد اصول تزيد قيمتها عن 20 مليار و 500
مليون دولار مملوكه
للايجارش وافراد اخرين وشركات
طبعا لندن فرضت حتى الان عقوبات على اكثر
من
1200 فرد من بينهم رجال اعمال سياسيون
واكثر من 120 كيانا في روسيا
ان هذا موضوع طبعا معقد ونحاول ان نفهمه
من ضيفنا الان من لندن والبروفيسور برايم
ستاركس مدير تحرير مجله الاقتصاد العالمي
والمحاضر في جامعه باكيهم
سيسترز هل هي قرصنه
القرن الواحد والعشرين ام فعلا اجراء عقاب
مبرر قانونيا
موجود طبعا لكن ما نتحدث عنه حتى الان هو
من الاصول المجمده
المصور المجمده تختلف عن الاصول المصادره
اذا جانب القانوني
للاموال او الاصول المصادره ممكن ان
تستخدم لاعاده بناء الاقتصاد الاخراني
بسبب ما تتضرر بسبب الحق به من ضرر يبدو
جميلا ان نتحدث عن مصادره اصول روسيه لكن
حاليا هي مجمده في الحقيقه وليست مصادره
لهذا السبب فان هناك جانبا قانوني
هناك هناك طبعا سوابق في التجميد اكثر من
وجود سوابق في المصادره وحتى على مستوى
المفاوضين الاوروبيه تتطلب عملا او قانونا
من جانب البرلمان لكن التعقيد هنا ايضا
موجود
ويتعلق هل هذه
ستنطبق على اصول تعود للدوله الروسيه ام
لافراد
روسيا قانونيه الامر
الولايات المتحده تجاوزتها
بايضا يتحدث عن اليه لتجميد الاموال الان
يعني هل تجاوزنا الجانب القانوني لحتى
يتحدث عن الاليه
مين سيجاره
ولكن
المتحده تحاول ارسالها قواعد اللعبه هنا
اذا كنا نتحدثون عن الغاز الغير المشروع
ماذا عن العراق العراق
تعويض الفلسطينيين الذين صادرت اسرائيل
على اراضيهم هذه المساله هي في غايه
التعقيد الان الوقت المتحده والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه تحاوضان
على عمليات وساوى وسائل قانونيه تتماشى مع
القانون الدولي لو ان روسيا مثلا ثلاث
مرات اموالا في الصين اليس هذا استثمارا
اجنبيه
مشروعا والذي يتفقوا مع القواعد الدوليه
المتفق التي تحول دون الاصطلاح على
الاموال المستثمره اذا عليك ان تجد
تبحث عن عن اصول خاصه اصول مملوكه للدول
امرها يختلف والتي يجب ان نقرر هل هي لها
علاقه
بالغاز ام لا وهي مساله تفتحوا ابوابا لا
حصل لها من التعقيدات فانت اذا ما فتحت
هذا الباب عليك ايضا ان تفحص في مسؤول
العقارات وفي مساله العقارات
كما ذكرت خطير ومعقد والسؤال كيف سيؤثر
على الاقتصاد العالمي حاليا وهل سيدفع
مثلا دول الى ان تمتنع عن وضع اصول ماليه
لها في الخارج يعني همم هل هذه فاتحه اللي
مثل هذا الامر باجازه لو سمحت
يا ابو السيد
في اخر مره تم فيها
فرض
تعويضات على بلد سبب الحرب كان في عقاب
الحرب العالميه في وفقه معاهده فارسي
والتي ادت فيما ادت اليه الى انهيار كامل
لاحقا في الاقتصاد العالمي والاستثمار
القالب وقد كانت هناك التحضيرات على ضروره
عظمه الذهاب قدما في ذلك
اتجاه هذا في الحرب العالميه الاولى
اختلف بدلا من معاقبه بلد واحد كان هناك
جهد مشترك من جنب راس المتحده
اوروبا اذا العقوبه تتعلق شكرا
شكرا
لكم ادركنا الوقت توصلنا الى منتصف الليل
بتوقيت بكت المكرمه وهذا استعراض لاهم
الانباء قبل الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه
يوميات المونديال
فقط الاوروبيون في الاتفاق على السقف
لاسعار النفط والغاز الروسيين وقرر
الوزراء بحث الامر مجددا في اجتماعي منتصف
الشهر المقبل غير ان الوزراء اتفقوا على
اليه المشتركه لشراء الغاز قال الرئيس
الامريكي جومادا في تصريحات للصحفيين
الخميس انه مقترحه واشنطن والحلفاء بوضع
سقفا لسعر النفط الروسيه لا يزال قائما
مضيفا انه تحدث الى وزيره الخزانه جانه
هيلين بهذا الشان في المقابل قال الكلام
لان الرئيس الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين اكد
انه وضع سقف لسعر النفط الروسي ستكون له
عواقبه وخيمه على اسواق الطاقه العالميه
وكان بوتن اصدر تعليمات بعدم تزويد الدول
التي ستنضم الى وضع سقف عند اسعار الطاقه
الرئيس الاوكراني بلوديفير زنسكي في
مقابله مع الفاينال شيل تايمز قال انه لن
يكون هناك حل دائما للصراع دون انسحاب
روسيا من كافه الاراضي الاكرانيه واضاف ان
المساعي الى حل لا يشمل السعاده شبه جزيره
القرم مضيعه الوقت وشدد الرئيس الاوكرانيه
على ان الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه تؤكد ان موسكو لا تنوي التفاوض
لانهاء الحرب
اما تركيا فاقد كشفت قصفها على مواقع عم
تعرف بقوه سوريا ديمقراطيه شمالي سوريا
وفي اتصال ان هاتفيا بين وزير الدفاع
التركي ونظيره الروسي اكدت انقره استمرار
عملياتها للقضاء بشكل نهائي على التهديد
الذي تمثله المنظمات
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الوقف الفوري
للتصعيد شماليه سوريا سوريا
اذا هذه فرحه الجماهير البرازيليه بالفوز
على صربيا اليوم اذا ستتابعون طبعا
التفاصيل هذه الصور من ريو دي جانيرو لكم
ان تتخيلوا فرحه الجماهير البرازيليه هنا
في الدوحه ايضا على العموم ستتابعونها
بتفصيل اكبر في يوميات موندياليه مع زميلي
مع عزبه لحيه بعد قليل اما انا فاختم
الحصاد اشكركم على المتابعه
[موسيقى]